foreign
that as a professional tree hugger I'm
going to be speaking to you about Supply
chains they don't sound very sexy but
when it comes to stabilizing our climate
Supply chains are the hottest topic on
the planet
and that's because more than half of our
society's carbon footprint can be
attributed to the impact of Supply
chains and specifically the raw
materials that products are made from
we have built our societies around take
make waste production systems the fossil
fuel industry Plastics industrial
forestry and paper these are massive
Global Supply chains that have shaped
our wealth they've left deep scars
across Landscapes legacies of pollution
and push species and cultures to the
brink of Extinction now on the other
hand we have game-changing Solutions
brilliant innovations that use 90
percent less water and 50 percent less
energy but they're stuck at small scale
because they can't secure the financing
that they need to commercialize not the
markets that underpin their success
it's the classic chicken and egg
situation and even with slow progress
we're losing ground to The Climate
crisis and biodiversity loss
this at a moment when we need all hands
on deck for our planet we must scale
Solutions and we must scale them quickly
and this is not just about doing less
bad if that time has passed we need the
2.0 Industrial Revolution one that sets
us on course to operate and live within
the natural bounds of our planet
and so overhauling these huge and
Powerful entrenched Industrial Systems
it can appear daunting
but I've seen how change can be
successful up close with the work that
I've been doing for the past 20 years
from my organization canopy
our focus is on protecting the world's
ancient and endangered forests and
transforming the massive pulp paper
packaging and viscose Supply chains but
the principles
from those Supply chains can be applied
to any sector in need of change keeping
far standing is one of the fastest
cheapest most effective ways for us to
stabilize our climate but of course we
can't keep far standing if we keep
mowing them down to make pizza boxes and
rayon t-shirts the surge in e-commerce
and fashion derived from tree based
textiles like rayon and viscose is
driving the destruction of climate
critical forests and creating mountains
of discarded textiles and packaging we
must move our supply chains out of
forest ecosystems and to do that we need
to change the business practices of
thousands of Brands and that's where we
come in canopy Works to create the
market conditions for change by working
with hundreds of the forest industry's
largest customers first to eliminate the
use of ancient and endangered Forest
fiber from their packaging and their
textile Supply chains and now
increasingly to introduce lower carbon
circular next-gen alternatives
get rid of the bed phase in scale up the
good
these companies are often Fierce
competitors in the rest of their
business operations but they're willing
to come together in a pre-competitive
space because they know that no single
company no matter how large they are can
transform an entire Supply Chain by
themselves nor can they solve the
climate crisis
and the CEOs of these company suppliers
giant companies responsible for 90 of
Global viscose Production and half of
packaging can sit around a single
boardroom table imagine that the
outsized influence of this small group
of suppliers can unlock ambitious levels
of change through their Collective
Supply chains and of course the same can
be said for other sectors as well
supply chain transformation starts when
you have a critical mass of Brands
telling the suppliers that they need to
change that they have zero tolerance for
packaging and textiles that originate
from the world's endangered forests that
they want lower carbon circular next-gen
Alternatives and giving their suppliers
a short timeline to achieve that Target
and this strong Market pull through for
low carbon alternative creates the value
proposition for conventional producers
to change business as usual practice to
fund the new tech to develop the systems
to replace tree fiber with these lower
carbon more circular feedstocks like
discarded clothing and Agricultural
residues and then to build the systems
to make sure that these new feedstocks
can then make their way to the new
next-gen pulp Mills a canopy we call
this strategy survival a pulp Thriller
foreign
thank you
so industry leaders demand change
suppliers respond it creates value that
moves investment the pipeline of
solutions is buoyed and you have a
supply chain well on its way to
sustainable change
canopies only work Greening the Harry
Potter book series has grown to working
with brands that represent a trillion
dollars these companies are changing the
packaging and the viscose textiles that
they're buying based on the
environmental qualities and it is this
leverage that has enabled us to shift
more than half of global viscose out of
the world's ancient and endangered
forests
and now we're working with our brand
partners with conventional producers
with investors and with brilliant
innovators to scale climate resilient
Supply chains for the 21st century and
in fact the world's first next-gen Mill
is now up and running it's a giant
industrial Mill built in the bones of an
old shuttered windmill in Northern
Sweden and rather than requiring huge
swaths of forest to be cut every year
renew cell will use hundreds of millions
of old jeans and t-shirts it's
re-employed a hundred people it uses 90
percent less water and five tons less
carbon per ton of product compared to a
conventional tree based ramp renew cell
is a spectacular swords to plowshare's
example and it is the first of hundreds
of next-gen Mills that are on track to
be operational by 2030 as our strategy
unfolds and boosted by the generous
support of the Ted community
it's heartening and remarkable to see
the viscose supply chain transforming in
real time and proving that Solutions are
indeed sexy but it mustn't stop there
because many of our production systems
and Supply chains are unsustainable and
in need of change the food system
Plastics paper-based Packaging
for every sector there is a more
sustainable path forward and the
solutions and the people needed to make
them happen are often closer than we
think
when we create the right market
conditions change can happen
exponentially and quickly
carbon intensive Supply chains are
relics of the 20th century let's leave
them back there thank you
[Applause]